before you were ever even in any movies
you were like a bona fide celebrity
within the prison yeah right and that
was kind of how you ended up getting
your first real role right like when uh
you were you were just on a set randomly
like for some other cat
right and then the director says dude
you're dating me
up from the prison it wasn't director it
was eddie bunker who is who was a
prolific writer before he passed away if
you want to read a good criminal novel
pick up
education of a felon
right i read that when i was 18. and i
and and i couldn't believe the stories
that were in there and then when you
when you mentioned them in the in the
documentary i was like oh [ __ ] like this
guy was the real deal for real i
remember one time when my kid
gilbert was uh was uh
uh on the lamb you know and he told me i
need some money i went to give him some
money and he was with like four of his
friends and uh
his friends me and eddie bunker went to
meet gilbert and we saw him and uh we
handed out gave him some money it'd be
cool be careful and then he'll come over
to my house and uh one of the kids
what's the meanest looking white dude
i've ever seen eddie bunker he had this
he had this
even the way he talked when he said
hello it sounded like i want to do a
robbery
it was just the way it was it was just
just this whole you wanna do a robbery
just the way it sounded yeah and uh
and he said that's the meanest little
white man i've ever seen in my life and
and so when i ran into him on runaway
train
he said trey are you still boxing like
well i trained all i'm 40 years old i
don't fight no more and he says
we need somebody to train one of the
actors how to box now they're giving you
50 bucks
cash to be extra right
and
he leans over and says uh well they'll
pay you 320 a day
and i'm i said
how bad you want this guy beat up
no
i wasn't making three i was a drug
counselor i wasn't making 320 a week you
know what i mean
how about you when this guy beat up
hopes and he goes no no no no you got to
be careful holmes it's like a he might
suck you
i said he for 320 i could still [ __ ]
[ __ ] i didn't do that for free
and i started training eric roberts how
to box for a movie called runaway train
and eric in 1968 1985 was kind of a
loose cannon you know he was a movie
star you know movie stars are dick and
and so
i started training him and the director
kind of saw
that uh
eric respected me
so
he would do whatever i said and and uh
andre kozilowski comes over to
you be in movie
you fight eric in movie
and you be my friend and then he leans
over and he kisses me on both cheeks
right and walks away because he's like a
russian aristocrat and first of all
if you have a prison background and
somebody says you'd be my friend it's
like you can't wait a minute hold on
[Laughter]
and then
and then he kissed me right he walked
away and i looked at eddie hey look i'm
gonna train the kid for 320 but if i'm
gonna kiss that old man i want more
money
whoa you're european
i didn't [ __ ] that man
he says well they kissed and so
so i started training eric roberts for
the runaway train because they asked
eric who do you want
to to fight with you the guy they had
picked was a pretty latin dude i mean he
was and eric roberts he prettier than
his sister you know i mean so so they
got two pretty kids fighting
in a prison and it looked like the
battle of two queens you know so
so andre kept saying
contrast
contrast he go to eric go ah
and then he come to me go
i turned eddie
is he clowning me and he goes trail shut
up and so i just i dummied but i got a
sag guard and i trained eric roberts i
fought eric roberts in the movie runaway
train and that's how i got
in the movies and the first five years
of my career
i played inmate number one bad guy
chicano dude tattooed dude
[Laughter]
i've never had a name the first name i
got
was art sanella i played an italian
in depth wish four
with charles bronson i got to meet big
charlie
that's great that's great yeah you ever
get any fights on the movie sets or
people are pretty scared of you i've
i've had to calm a few people down and
tell them i'll beat you to death
[Laughter]
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats